what is going on everybody welcome to
the seventh Monte Carlo and Python
tutorial video in the last video we kind
of saw some of the statistics and
visually saw how well the whole double
or a better guy does the next question
that is pretty much inevitable is how
does this guy fare compared to our other
better the simple better where is he
I don't think we deleted him always down
here anyway so that's what we want to do
in this video is kind of compare these
guys and see who is the superior so with
that what we're going to want to do is
kind of make some edits here so they
both are plotted up and so the first
thing that we want to do is we'll just
delete this for now and we'll just
comment this stuff out because we don't
need it for now once you've done that
last thing we want to do is go to our
simple better and he needs a let's see I
guess for now let's just get simple
better so we have the results from
before with the death rate and their
survival rate so we'll run the same sort
of tests and again those were given to
us with I believe we were doing a
thousand wagers so anyway we'll just
kind of play around with that and see
the survival rate of our simple better
next so what we'll do here is we will
global again rope count and we'll come
down here and rope count plus equals one
whenever he goes broke and then here we
just start broken zero thousand this
should be honest I can't remember I
don't know if we were doing a thousand
or ten thousand to get those numbers I
think it was just a thousand so now but
we could just compare the ending
survival rate which was a survival rate
of 70 percent
at this amount here so a hundred waiters
so let's do that one first since we're
positive on that 100 waiter wagers and I
think we did 10,000 betters up here nope
we only did a thousand okay so ten
thousand wagers at that or a thousand
yet I can't even speak 100 waiters and a
thousand samples so a thousand betters
basically broke camp and then down here
we'll do basically the same thing we did
up here so I'm just gonna copy and paste
this paste should be everything we need
to do I feel like I ran through this
really quickly though so we'll find out
real quick if I did something wrong name
error X X is not fine of course it's not
delete delete' matplotlib is gonna be so
angry at me well we left that chart up
oh my goodness it's gonna get angry
should give me one more of those errors
oh well anyway we'll run it again there
it is it's waiting for you okay so here
we can see that actually nobody died
right the death rate is zero survival
rate is a hundred so everybody lived but
as we can see not everybody did well but
everybody lives some people actually did
make a good healthy profit some of these
guys made it to 13,000 even so similar
profits but as we can see the long long
term if you were gonna make a lot of
wagers the doubler obviously does much
better than this guy because this guy on
a long-term scale will lose 100% as we
already found out so let's go ahead and
make it a thousand wagers now and see
how much that changes our death and
survival rate so now we can see that a
couple people have died not many but a
few and let's go ahead and make this a
larger sample and then we'll do 10,000
here let's do a hundred thousand and we
will see this should make a significant
difference so while we're waiting I
guess I could probably just pause this
this might take a while right well that
is just taking way too long I even
lowered the number
250-thousand so we'll see but anyway if
it pops up on talking great if it
doesn't we'll just stop the video so
already so far we can see that at least
a couple of variables that must come
into play regardless of what strategy
you use is the wager size in terms of
percent in relation to how much you're
starting wealth is and then also how
many wagers are we doing so some of
these strategies have basically a life
expectancy long-term of zero ok so the
simple better for example he is
basically 100% certain to lose his money
long term he he has no option if he
plays long enough he will lose money
then you've got the double or better who
conceivably even on the longest scale
some of these double betters are gonna
make it through I mean on an infinitely
long scale I suppose they all would in
theory lose but for the most part he
actually seen as a chance of making
possibly some money but he's gonna most
likely go broke so for the double or
better he's got even another variable
which is how much you know right now
he's doubling but is there a different
multiple that is better and then also
you have the question of how many wagers
should he do before returning back to
his initial state so if the survival
rate is over 50% and you've got an over
50% chance of doubling your money let's
say or just at least adding to your
money I suppose it would have to be
doubling your money though then it would
be wise to keep playing so say you had
$10,000 you would keep playing and if
you've made more than $10,000 on average
you would just keep doing this and at a
certain point you would start all over
and say okay I've got $10,000 to play
with again and keep doing that stuff
like that so the question is does this
exist is there a strategy that works
like that and if so can we find it so
anyways that's what we're seeking out
here still have not had this chart pop
up so I'll just stop it here you should
just understand that the survival rates
of the simple better sure
term is gonna be really really good long
term it will die and then also medium
term it's just not going to make very
much money it might survive but the
actual profits will not be the same as
the survivors of the double or better so
anyways that's gonna conclude this video
as always thanks for watching